vous savez c'est à partir d'aujourd'hui
que la deuxième phase de la charte des
voyageurs entrent en vigueur cette
charte qui est supposé d'être les
meilleurs au monde selon le ministre des
transports marc garneau dans désormais
les compagnies aériennes vont être tenu
des mises et les passagers en cas
d'annulation ou de retard
on va en discuter tout de suite avec
jacob charbonneau cofondateur et pdg de
vol en france charbonneau bonjour vous
la connaissez très bien la nouvelle
charte des voyageurs qui est entré en
partie en vigueur en juillet dernier
aujourd'hui des nouvelles mesures
quelles sont elles parce qu'on prévoit
partir d'aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment
la portion des indemnités a donc
souhaité aller retard suite avisé
l'annulation voire doit avoir des
compensations en argent donc c'est une
portion qui est importante mais aussi
toutes les règles minimales qui doivent
être respectées par les lignes aériennes
donc notamment au niveau de la prise en
charge des passagers et du
réacheminement parfait on va regarder ça
on le prépare et des tableaux c'est pour
synthétiser cette charte la alors par
exemple des indemnités qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 1000 dollars en cas de retard ou
d'annulation
ça c'est pour les gros transporteurs
donc on peut parler ici d'art canada
westjet sans wing entre autres étaient
tous les transporteurs qui transporte
plus de 2 millions de passagers par
année
ok puis indemnités allant jusqu'à 500
dollars en cas de retard ou d'annulation
pour les petits transporteurs
est ce que ce sont les indemnités
vraiment qui sont versés en argent ou
c'est un crédit sur un nouveau billet
qu'on pourrait acheter par exemple
c'est une instruction de question en
fait dans tous les cons doit se faire
offrir de l'argent sonnant la ligne
aérienne peut quand même offrir des
coupons si elle est à faire de l'argent
ça doit être majoré donc on doit offrir
les deux choix est majoré la portion
coupant qui elle ne doit plus avoir de
la d'expiration donc qu'est ce qu'on
doit se battre comme voyageurs comme
passager pour obtenir ses limites et là
effectivement si pas toujours simple
donc c'est pas quelque chose
d'automatique la seule portion qui est
automatique qui est prévu dans la charte
c'est vraiment la portion de
surréservation et encore c'est une
portion qui rentrait au 15 juillet déjà
eu beaucoup beaucoup de plaintes au
niveau de l'office des transports du
canada pour le non respect des gens qui
n'ont pas eu leur
même des biens qui ont été sur réserviez
et que ça doit être automatique ça c'est
quand une compagnie aérienne réserve de
la place pour trop de passagers par
rapport à la capacité de l'avion c'est
exactement là ils doivent trouver des
volontaires en premier c'est pas trop
longtemps une force des gens dont on
déplace des gens qui ont pourtant un vol
confirmé et là il doit avoir des
indemnités qui vont jusqu'à 2400 $ ces
indemnités là doivent être automatique
dons versés sur le champ ou dans les 48
heures et l'on se rend compte que
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui se
plaignent parce que c'est pourquoi les
compagnies aériennes sont réfractaires à
lâcher un petit peu déjà eu des amendes
qui ont été versées notamment au niveau
de l'information qui doit être présente
dans les avez ou pas donc dans un
premier temps l'orne les gens qui n'ont
pas les reins des multi nécessairement
pour la surréservation donc on espère
que pour la deuxième portion pour la
portion des retards annulations savatan
suivi un petit peu plus serré et puis
que ça va être plus facile d'obtenir les
coupables comment ça fonctionne
justement latium mécanisme qui est mis
en place pour que le client puisse faire
valoir à la compagnie aérienne qu' il ya
une identité qui doit lui être versée ou
c'est vraiment david contre goliath
c'est un peu david contre goliath en
fait chaque ligne en a sa propre façon
de faire c'est pas toujours ça il faut
connaître ses droits dès fois on reçoit
un refus ou des fois il ya des
conditions le diaraf et un problème
météo alors que c'est précisément comme
d'hab c'est vraiment drôle qu'on joue
nous on s'assurerait on s'assure que les
gens obtiennent leurs indemnités donc on
a fait un service clé en main mon info
si des gens qui ont eu un refus ou qui
veut lever le ds qui ont eu le bon
montant est ce qu on a eu une bonne
réponse que la réponse dany rien nous a
donné c'est la bonne raison du retard ou
l'annulation parce que le fardeau de la
preuve servions passagers oui exactement
donc c'est pas toujours simple pour le
passager puis je vous donne un exemple
les indemnités ajoutant
l'internalisation en cas de bris
mécanique ne donne pas le droit à une
compensation sauf ça a été relevé au
niveau de la maintenance
c'est quasiment impossible pour le
passage et de savoir si c'est un
problème qui étaient relevés au niveau
de la maintenance ou pas donc et
certains critères comme ça qui sont pas
toujours simple ils n'ont évidemment
bien la dame on a des gens qui font la
recherche à jouer long pour savoir c'est
quoi le nouveau jugement sco les
nouveaux règlements
les tarifs qui font 150 pages quand on
achète un billet d'avion et personnes
qu'ils y sont
donc évidemment des trophées de tous ces
règlements lost pas toujours si c'est
pas évident déjà qu'on a beaucoup de
choses à préparer pour le voyage
la charte est ce qui s'est passé
exactement on ne sait pas toujours
on veut terminer en présentant l'autre
tableau qu'on avait préparé concernant
les mesures qui entrent en vigueur
aujourd'hui c'est la nourriture
gratuitement sur un vol qui est retardé
ou annulé et la sélection gratuite des
sièges pour les enfants donc ça c'est à
partir d'aujourd'hui oui pis encore ils
les critères donc niveau de la
nourriture gratuite par exemple qu'on
parle de cette prise en charge la savait
pas combien de temps avant ont été
avisés du retard ou de l'annulation au
niveau de la sélection de sièges donc ça
c'est très intéressant par contre ça
dépend de la disponibilité ça dépend de
l'âge des enfants pour savoir à quel
proximité les enfants vont pouvoir être
est ce que c'est un grand changement
à votre avis c'est un pas dans la bonne
direction je pense qu'on a des règles
minimales maintenant qu'ils existent il
s'agit que les gens les connaissent
c'est sûr que c'est pas aussi clair et
c'est pas aussi simple que ce qu'on peut
voir au niveau européen mais au moins on
a quelque chose pour travailler puis
pour aider très bien jacob charbonneau
merci de nous en a beaucoup